The space shuttle Challenger disaster
could be traced to ONE mistake:
the failure of these black rubber bands.
They were meant to seal the
right solid rocket booster joint.
The O-rings were supposed to move into the
groove to prevent the hot gases from leaking.
But the cold weather caused both the
primary and backup O-ring to stiffen,
so they failed to stop the gas from escaping.
To test this theory, scientist Richard Feynman
dunked a rubber O-ring into a glass of ice water.
Clip It doesn’t stretch back; it stays the same
dimension. I believe that has some significance
for our problem.
This discovery put Feynman on
the map. For the full video on
his incredible life, the link is in my comments.